let me say at the start I fully expect
to lose this debate because I've done
these debates before and what I found is
the Bitcoin people at the beginning vote
that they're in favor of gold just so
they can switch to bitcoin at the end so
that Bitcoin can win so I'm prepared for
that uh but anyway and you know the
other thing about these gold versus
Bitcoin type debates is that in reality
Bitcoin and gold have absolutely nothing
in common I mean Bitcoin part of the
marketing fraud is to try to portray
Bitcoin as gold gold 2.0 digital gold I
mean Bitcoin itself is always displayed
as a coin and the color is gold and you
put like a B on it uh but it's not a
coin it's just a digital string of
numbers it doesn't have any substance it
doesn't have any color and what made
gold money was the properties that gold
the element possesses as a metal as a
commodity Bitcoin doesn't possess any of
the metallic properties that gives gold
value now what Bitcoin tried to mimic
was some of the other qualities that
made gold a better form of money than
other Commodities that could be and have
been used as money you see by definition
money is simply the most marketable
commodity and yes Anthony mentioned that
we used to have barter and money was an
invention that made trade more efficient
because barter is inherently very
inefficient and so the invention of
money was a major progress as far as
human history is concerned and a lot of
things were money before gold ultimately
emerged as the best money because it
satisfied the qualities of money best
and some of the qualities that gold had
the visibility portability fungibility
these are some of the properties that
Bitcoin copied but without the
fundamental value of gold a medal
Bitcoin can never be money because money
has to be a store of value and a lot of
people in the crypto Community try to
claim that Bitcoin is a store of value
because if you bought it 10 11 years ago
the price has gone up well there's a
difference between a price and value the
reason that gold is a store of value is
because you're storing the value of the
metal gold gold can be used to do all
sorts of things sure you could use it
for jewelry I got a gold watch on that's
that's made of jewelry and a lot of the
gold is used in jewelry but gold is used
in industry it's used in Aerospace
medicine Dentistry there's all sorts of
Demands for gold the metal because it is
the most use useful metal on the
periodic table and even if I'm not going
to use the gold myself for any of those
uses even I'm if I'm just going to store
gold coins or gold bars you know in my
in my safe what I am doing is storing
the future use of gold because gold does
not lose any of its properties over time
that's what makes it such a good store
of value because in a 100 years in a
thousand years the gold that I'm storing
today can be melted down and used in
electronics or using jewelry or for
whatever new uh uses have been invented
that don't even exist today in contrast
Bitcoin can't be a store of value
because it has no actual value to store
there's nothing I can do with my Bitcoin
today there's nothing anybody else can
do with it tomorrow sure you can give it
to somebody else you could trade Bitcoin
but why does somebody want your Bitcoin
because they think they can give it to
somebody else who thinks they can give
it to somebody else at at a higher price
this is a greater fool what Bitcoin in
effect is is kind of like a a
combination Ponzi scheme pyramid Chain
Letter the only value comes from the
belief that the Bitcoin can be sold in
the future to a greater fool who is
equally convinced he can sell it in the
future at a higher price this isn't
digital gold this is fool's gold this is
modern day Alchemy Bitcoin doesn't have
a future to me it's not gold 2.0 this is
tulip Mania 2.0 except tulips had more
intrinsic value than Bitcoin because at
the end of the day at least you had a
flower thank you minutes I actually
actually you were five and a half so
I'll give you your 30 seconds back I owe
you one
right right okay so now we're we're
going to start getting in some audience
questions please do submit yours you do
it on the Q&A button I'm going to spend
a few minutes basically just nagging the
panelists to see if I can get a bit more
value out test some of their own
convictions because I always feel when
people come in as convinced as these two
are there must be a soft Edge to their
argument a cliff Edge that we could
perhaps pray but the main thing I'd
really like you to do audience we've got
a lot of subscribers on this call please
to send in your questions I'm far better
at this if you send me questions
otherwise I'll just uh rabit on and I
think it would be much nicer to to have
some questions we've got a few in
already so let's get them in and of
course you can tweet as well hashtag iq2
crypto okay so I'm gonna start with you
Anthony I when you say this this is in a
sense a bit of a breakthrough moment one
thing I would like to know from you is
what is the problem to which
cryptocurrency is the answer we'll come
on to whether it's a bubble in a minute
and whether you owe each other a tulip
or not but is there something that is
really going on here or is it just kind
of a nice idea because we've got the
technology so we might as
well well listen there's a there's a lot
going on I mean uh I just 30 seconds of
addressing Peter I think it's important
if you accept that we've moved into a
digital society and if you accept that
uh we're adopting things on the internet
and so therefore there is value on the
internet example facebook.com that URL
has value
amazon.com has value and so then the
question is does the Bitcoin Network
itself have value and I believe it does
it's at 125 million users right now I
think it's going to a billion users I
think Kathy Wood is going to be correct
billion users by the end of 2025 and so
we we would go to Professor Robert
medcafe at MIT and we would say Dr medf
does a network in itself have value and
I think the answer to that is yes to
answer your question
specifically um we have a tendency to
corrupt our money uh we've been doing
that forever uh this is the 50th
Anniversary since the abrogation of the
Breton Woods treaty by Richard Nixon on
August 15
1971 and and to Peter I'll make a point
on Peter's behalf we were measuring
these currencies in Gold 50 years ago
$35 an ounce uh for gold in 1971 it's
roughly 1,700 or so dollars an ounce
today we've corrupted our money there's
some best-selling books behind Peter
about the great crash and the overall
Corruption of money and I've read those
books that Peter's written I would
encourage everybody to read them because
he's explaining that when you start to
corrupt the money every single person on
this call tonight has been jipped some
way or taxed some way by a central
Banker as a result of that money
prerational of Bitcoin there are 21
million coins out there several million
of which have left to be mined but two
or three million that were likely lost
and as a result of early adoption poor
storage and you know there are 49
million Global millionaires according to
JP Morgan we don't even have enough
Bitcoin for each Global millionaire to
own one Bitcoin and if you believe that
that network has value Peter is
suggesting that it doesn't because all
it is is a cryptograph on the internet
um but I would suggest that that Network
itself is very very valuable it's a
trusted Network and the Breakthrough for
me is it's a Libertarian concept I have
this code I can transfer it to you as a
representation of a ledger of the money
in my pocket that's a ledger this this
piece of fabric is really not worth
anything but somebody believes that it
is and we have to sof that because this
is being printed now in a massively
corruptive way around this it's like 31%
increase in M2 since April of
2020 that is a good point point with
remembering on on the supply side let me
put the broader point there across to
Pizer which As I understood it is that
the network itself has value that you
can argue about what is going to happen
to to the currencies and we might we
might talk about that in a minute what
the risks are inherently but that the
network in itself is growing has value
and has Believers Peter isn't that in
itself something that you should
consider well you know first of all the
the point that that we're addressing
here about the I agree you know yes
paper money Fiat money is a huge problem
and intrinsically it has no value the
value of that piece of paper that
Anthony is holding on to comes
predominantly from Faith you know when
we had real money you didn't have to
have faith because you had gold you had
a real commodity and everybody knew its
value because everybody knew what you
can you can do with gold uh but fiat
currency people just believe it has
value but it also gets value from the
fact that governments declare it as
legal tender and governments require the
payment of taxes in that currency and so
there is a natural demand nobody wants
to go to jail so everybody needs dollars
in order to pay their taxes and so
that's where the value comes from the
problem with Bitcoin one of the many
problems is its value comes from the
same thing it's confidence you have to
believe that it has value you have to
believe that other people are going to
want it maybe you have to believe in
this network but at the end of the day
it's value is derived from confidence
and belief except you don't even have
the government behind it to force you to
pay taxes in it so I think it's much
easier for that faith and that
confidence to be lost you know and you
know Bitcoin was the first
cryptocurrency there's now over 11,000
other ones that exist I mean who's to
say uh that Bitcoin uh won't be p a that
some of these other coins will become
more popular and people will forget
about Bitcoin I mean generally the first
mover is not always the last mover uh
somebody invents or builds a bigger
bigger mouse trap would that would that
not would that not be a challenge to
youer because that would simply show
that someone or you group behind it were
better at it than Bitcoin it wouldn't
disprove the argument would it it would
simply say well these V currencies are
working well no because I think the fact
that you can always come up with another
one destroys the argument that they're
scar it there I mean you're not going to
come up with a better gold gold is gold
uh but you know I can keep inventing
these cryptocurrencies there's no limit
to the supply of cryptocurrencies and I
don't know that necessarily if you can
assign a value to the network if that
value inur to the individual uh you know
Satoshi that everybody owns and you know
I know that yeah we're we're going
digital a lot of things now are digital
but that doesn't mean that everything is
digital I don't live in a digital house
I don't eat digital food I don't drive a
digital car and I'm not going to have
digital money because money is a
commodity it is a real thing it cannot
just be replicated digitally if you want
to have a store of value if you want
real money then you need something like
gold if you believe in Fiat money well
then you can have Fiat cryptocurrencies
but the problem is again you're playing
a confidence game only without the the
the government supports and all the
other infrastructure the price
structures uh you know uh the the
insurance products the bond markets all
the all the the the the things that
people use Fiat currencies for today
they don't use they don't use Bitcoin
for any of that other than just trading
people collect Bitcoin let me kick that
back to Anthony just so that when we get
to the the half hour we can go to the
audience because I've got some very good
questions thank you very much audience
and and do keep them coming and I'll try
and group them as as
sensibly as I can Anthony I'm actually
speaking to you from the Baltic state so
I've been speaking to and talking to
people who are obviously very keen on on
digital it's interesting at the point we
don't have a digital car well we don't
although I feel I've got near as dam it
a digital car I got a car from from Bolt
one of the big you know car apps up here
I did it all on the app I turned up open
sesame the key was there literally the
car was physical but nothing else was
even so I say you talking to kak kalis
the very go ahead prime minister of
Estonia on digital yesterday
cryptocurrency she said I don't I don't
yet see that would Inspire confidence
and if you are getting to the point
where your your argument is quite well
advanced IT exists in the real world and
yet governments are still very Cherry
very leery of it there might be a
problem around that am I
right um I had that view that you're
sharing with me uh that the prime
minister of Estonia or the president of
Estonia had uh if you were talking to me
in 2017 or 2018 I would have said had
this higher level of skepticism uh when
I left the White House you know people
forget that I was also at the XM bank
and I spent several weeks at the XM Bank
examining the XM Bank as its Chief
strategy officer making a recommendation
to the administration whether or not we
should keep the XM bank and at that time
they were talking about the digitization
of the dollar and the threat of a
digital Yuan and when I when I when I
was fired from the White House and went
back to my business it's one of the
great things about being an entrepreneur
we after you fired you go back to your
own business big deal I bought the URL
skybridge bitcoin.com because it became
very clear that the Fiat currencies were
going to start digitizing so what I
would say the Estonian government is I
understand your concern but there's been
exponential growth in the network the
network has moved from 30 million users
at that time to 125 million users on its
way to 180 by year end and so as more
and more users join the network the Fe
comple of the network will be such that
it'll be impossible not to have it as a
part of our lives and and what I would
say to Peter about gold I respect gold
and I understand Gold's cultural and
historical tenants but software is
eating the world uh every book behind me
right now I can digest that book into
this Smartphone and then I have room for
my photos and and everything else and I
think what Mr Nakamoto or Mrs Nakamoto
the group known as Nakamoto suggested is
if we've got money and this is where
Peter and I would intellectually
disagree gold is just another
representation of value it is a ledger
the human beings for 5,500 years are
trying to come up with a ledger between
each other so that they can exchange
goods and services without bartering
gold is just another representation of
that so all Nakamoto is saying is uh
this meets the three tenants it's scarce
it can be networked and I can transfer
it to you in an impregnable way we don't
have to like or trust each other but I
can create that one-on-one experience
without having to go through a third
party one last Quick Point yeah quick
one back to Peter and then to the
audience because we got some great
questions you have to keep if we capture
a meteor very valuable one that's got a
quar trillion dollars worth of gold it's
going to super disrupt that market
Bitcoin can't be disrupted it can't be
recreated P very quick quick last
comeback there you you can Vol your
serve uh at the net and then we'll go to
the well first of all gold is not a
representation of anything gold is
itself it is a metal right it is a
commodity and prior to it being money it
was Bartered for other Commodities I
mean I could have some gold and you
could have some wheat and we could
exchange one commodity for another one
value for another so when gold became
money gold became accepted in exchange
for any other commodity but it was a
commodity itself Bitcoin does not
possess that property Bitcoin is not an
actual good so you know when you talk
about digital books or digital music you
know these things can be digitized uh
this is intangible I can read a book on
paper because what I'm reading are the
words and so you can transfer those
words to me digitally or on a piece of
paper the same thing with music I can
listen to an album that's playing on you
know a phonograph or I could listen to
you know an iPod or whatever it's the
the music which is digital but s other
Pro Commodities like gold is a physical
element it is a metal and it can't be
replaced with a digital representation
because I can't make this watch out of
digital gold I can't conduct electricity
with digital gold you have to understand
the difference when you are putting your
faith in Bitcoin there's nothing real
the price can implode at any minute you
are dependent on more and more people
deciding to adopt it why because they're
confident that they're going to get rich
and all they have to do is hold on to it
and never sell it and it will go up and
one day they're going to be rich well
eventually the supply of fools runs out
and the bottom drops out of the market
right okay I got loads of questions so
I'm going to encourage you to give your
answers in a piy and hiu like way so
that you're good value for anybody's
money however it is uh how about this
one LCS mysteriously from New York City
how are you how do we know if cryptos
are not an elaborate scheme by the
original whales cash out at once with
other whale
collaboration uh we had a couple of
questions along those lines the
suggestion that it was kind of a bit of
a rigged can you rig a bubble I don't
know but if you can rig a bubble you
know that was the the kind of suggestion
I suppose that goes to you Anthony in a
response from Peter I the very quick
answer is an anal analysis of the
wallets that are out there it's very
easy to find those wallets uh that was
probably true about Bitcoin in 2011 12
and
13 uh there's a way more diverse
portfolio of people in that Network
today and I would recommend a book
quickly Dominic Frisbee's book Bitcoin
the future of money you can buy that on
Amazon for
$15 uh he explains to you why that
misnomer about the whales and 200 or 300
people owning Bitcoin is a misnomer uh
and I probably can't do it justice and B
you don't believe the sort
ofpc but I can also prove it empirically
in terms of the way the where the yeah
but okay well here's a a challenge can I
respond to that oh I'm so sorry P come
back and then I'll throw you something
off back well a couple things one you
have no idea who owns those wallets so
the same people can own multiple wallets
so you don't really know but my th
thinking on the whales is I don't think
most of the whales got in at the very
beginning for pennies of Bitcoin but I
do think they were attracted to it and
loaded up on big positions somewhere you
know between 100 and a thousand I think
a lot of the big money got in and I
think they did coordinate a a highly
targeted marketing campaign in order to
pump up the market price of the Bitcoin
that they had Acquired and and so I
think they have been selling into the
hype and so in my mind it is a giant
pump and dump where the guys that got in
relatively early maybe not on the ground
floor but relatively early are
constantly trying to pump up the market
in order to generate a lot of enthusiasm
and moment mum and fomo so that they can
sell out uh you know gradually into this
Market that that they are creating and I
think it's part of the whole culture of
this hodal uh Diamond hands trying to
convince as many of the little guys to
never sell because if you're the big guy
and you're trying to unload your Bitcoin
you don't want everybody else selling at
the same time and screwing it up for you
so you want to convince all the new
people who are coming in that they can
buy Bitcoin now at 30 40,000 50,000 of
Bitcoin and it's going to go to a
million it's going to go to 10 million
you got to get those guys on board and
make sure they never sell so you can
keep getting rid of yours and that's
what I think is going on behind the
scenes right come on then I want I want
to go into some other things uh question
from uh Sarah what do you think about
digital currencies like a digital dollar
could this displace Bitcoin and gold and
obviously we know the bank of England is
also having a tentative but it has
actually put it into public domain so
not that tentative look at at possibly
uh looking at digital currency as well
so is there a sort of can you have a
halfway house on this which is sort of
addresses some of the concerns uh and
convictions on both sides of the
argument quick one on this please if you
could uh yeah Anthony then
Peter um you have to you have to repeat
it because it was a little garble I
apolog it was Technologic digital
currency I can answer it yes actually
Peter will go first then you hear Peter
you'll know and I think Anthony would
agree with my answer look I don't think
think a digital dollar is a threat to
bitcoin or gold I mean all a digital
dollar is is the same fiat currency we
have now you know tokenized I mean most
of our transactions in dollars are
already digital I mean I use my credit
card or debit card I mean I rarely pay
for anything in cash anyway uh but the
the problem with a digital dollar where
the threat lies is to our freedom is
into our privacy because at least if I'm
spending paper dollars I can buy
something without the government knowing
exactly what I bought and tracking
everything I do but the minute we get
rid of the physical paper and everything
is forced onto a digital Network the
government knows every single thing I
buy and when I bought it and who knows
how that information maybe it seems
innocent now but how it may one day be
used against me and also I think it will
make it even easier for the Federal
Reserve to pursue Reckless monetary
policy negative interest rates somehow
having an expiration date or all kinds
of crazy things to create even more
inflation so I think a a digital dollar
would even create more of a need to get
rid of the dollar and look for a viable
alternative I just don't think Bitcoin
would qualify I think gold
would
I